REAGAN: Hi, Data 2,100 students.
As a part two of our
introduction to programming,
we are going to work
through some examples today.
Now, what I would
like you to do is
when you click on the
examples up above,
that link to the Google Colab
examples, you'll come here
and you're going to
click Copy to drive.
And it's going to
create a copy for you
to complete in your
own personal drive.
So I'm going to rename
this Sigurd underscore
intro to programming,
and then that way you
can keep all of these
examples in your Google Drive.
They'll all be in a
Google Colab folder,
so that will be nice for you
as you study this content.
All right.
So when we're outputting
something in Python,
we output to the console
using the print function.
Now, I should say there's a
lot of other ways to output
things in Python,
but generally you're
going to print to the
console as we are learning.
So we can output
values from a variable.
So I can say print the value
from the variable x here.
That should be a little arrow.
This prints the value
of that variable x.
Then we can output text values.
So the text needs to be here in
straight quotes and this outputs
"happy day."
Then we also have this can
combine text and variables.
We can say "Hello there" and
then I want to input the value
from the first name.
So we can just print values
like these literal values
here within those
literal values.
But we can also print values
from specific variables.
We can use this-- oftentimes
we'll do this using f-strings.
F-strings allow us to embed
expressions and variables
inside string literals
using curly braces.
This is preceded by an f to
denote a formatted string.
This makes them extremely
readable and concise.
--Examples document, I want
you to write a program that
assigns your name to
the variable, myName,
prints your name using
the variable myName,
and then say now
print my name is blank
using the variable myName.
Don't use f-strings or
Python placeholders.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So I want to say my name.
So I'm declaring that variable
using an assignment statement.
Say my name is equal to Reagan.
Then I want to print.
Actually, I'm going to run
that I guess really quick.
[LAUGHS] Then I'm going
to, as that's running,
I'm going to say Print my name.
You'll notice that when I ran
just my name equal to Reagan,
it just declared
the variable name.
It didn't actually
print anything.
So now if I say Shift
Enter, that will run.
And it will print
out to me, Reagan
Now, I want to print
my name is blank
using the variable, my name.
Don't use f-strings or
Python placeholders.
So let's take a look at this.
So what we'll do here is
I'll say print, my name is.
Then that's the end.
Those are my literal values.
I am typing in.
I want the literal
value, my name
is, to print, so I have those
within my quotation marks.
And then I want to
say print the value
from the variable, my name.
Then I also notice that I
have a period after my name.
So then I'll say oh, actually
add a period to that end.
So I'm saying, my name is,
that's all literal values.
Then I want to
place in the value
from the variable, my
name, and then we'll
place a period at the end.
Now when we run this.
We can see here that
my name is Reagan
and I have a space after
Reagan and after is.
So these commas, when
I have a comma here
that's separating these
parameters inside my print
statement, it's
adding a space there.
So what I can use is I can use
my separation method, which this
is not definitely not my
favorite way to do this,
but this is how we're supposed
to do it for this example.
But we can use our
separation and say
that I want to separate this.
I want to-- the commas
that are separating these.
These parameters
separate with nothing.
So I just have a
beginning and ending quote
with nothing in between.
So basically, when
I rerun this, you'll
notice what happens is it gets
rid of those extra spaces.
So the separate now has--
there's nothing in there, right.
We are not separating with
a space when I have commas.
We're saying don't
separate with anything.
But now I need to go back
in and add a space here.
After is before
Reagan prints, and now
I can see that my
name is Reagan.
Now, you'll notice that this
is a little bit of a rough.
A way to do this.
It's a lot harder than the way
that I'm going to show you now.
So now we're going to
write a program that
builds upon program 1.
So notice here that within my--
this is a Jupyter Notebook file.
We're using our
Jupyter Notebooks here
within Google Colab.
And once I run this
cell, my variables,
once I've ran the cell
that's created up here,
I can reference those
variables throughout the rest
of my Jupyter Notebook file.
So what.
You have to run
the cell in order
to be able to reference
the variables up above.
So here's a code cell.
Here's another code cell.
And these are just text cells.
So now we're going to write a
program that builds upon program
one, and we're going to use
variables from program one
to print out, my name is blank.
Use a variable, my
name, and use f-strings.
So again, because we're using
this Jupyter Notebook files,
these are just text.
This is actual code
that we're running.
Once I've ran this, I've
declared the variable my name.
And so I can reference that
variable my name down here
in my other code.
So now I want to print out
same thing, print my name
is, but I want to use
f strings this time.
So in order to use
f-strings right here,
before I begin printing out or
before I begin my literal values
that I want to print out,
I place just the letter
f there to tell I'm going
to use formatted strings.
I'm going to say my name is
then within curly brackets
I place the value or
the variable's name
that I want to place the
value of into this sentence.
So I want the value of my name
to be added to this sentence,
right here.
So basically, I'm going to have
Reagan replace that my name
variable once this is ran.
So now I run this and
we'll see that my name is
Reagan returns to me.
So we again, to use
formatted strings,
we place an f there
at the beginning
and then we have
our literal values,
my name is, then
within curly brackets,
we place the
variable's name that we
want to replace the value of.
So my name is Reagan.
All right, perfect.
Then for program 3,
we're going to do
a little bit of arithmetic.
So we have a lot of arithmetic
operators in Python.
There are addition
multiplication,
subtraction, division, we can
use exponents and remainders.
So that's the code
for each of them.
We're adding values, multiplying
values, subtracting values.
And we'll see here that
we're using these assignment
statements to say that y, the
variable y is equal to 4 plus 5.
So we know that y is
going to be equal to 9.
When we want to
use exponents, we
have to use those
double asterisks that
say 3 to the power of 7.
The remainder is kind
of an interesting one.
Basically the
remainder was going
to return just the remainder
of 43 divided by 10.
So 43 divided by 10 is
4 with a remainder of 3.
So remain here.
This variable is going
to be equal to 3,
which is the remainder
of 43 divided by 10.
So that's what the
remainder operation will do.
All right.
So let's go ahead and
use that arithmetic.
And we're going to write a
program that assigns your age
to the variable, My age.
So my age equal to, let's--
I'm not 35, but
let's say I'm 35.
All right.
And I'll say shift, enter.
OK, awesome.
So I'm going to say
after that I want
to multiply my age
variable by 12 to find out
how many months old I am.
In this same line of
code, assign this value
to my age and month,
then print this value.
So I'm going to say
my age and months
because I know that I want
to assign the output of 35
by 12 to my age in months.
When I'm declaring a variable
or assigning a variable,
that variable's name
must come first.
So I can't say 35 times 12
equal to my age in months.
I can't do that.
I must have my age
in months first,
I'm declaring that variable
and then I say 35 times is 12.
So now when I run this, I
hope that you're thinking,
am I going to receive
any output here?
So let's take a look.
And I don't actually receive
any output because I never
told it to print to my console.
It never printed
that code for me.
So I don't need to
do that or I don't
need to do anything
else with that per se,
but just know that those
variables are created
and now I can use them
right as I come down here
and I want to write
my new sentence,
I want to construct a sentence
that says, my name is blank
and I am blank, months old.
How old are you?
So I will say print and then
I want to use f-strings.
So I'll say f my name is.
And then I want to replace.
I want to place the value
from the variable name
to be right there.
And I am, again brackets,
my age in months old.
So I want to place value from
the variable age in months
to be here within
these curly brackets.
So now when I output this,
it'll say my name is Reagan
and I am 420 months old.
So here is these
programming examples for you
to continue to work
through as you would like.
A couple other things.
With Python, I can
concatenate values together.
So I can say x is
equal to Glacier.
Glacier is a literal
value plus rain
and that will have Glacier
rain to be the value of x.
I can also tell Python to
print in a particular way.
So I can use this
backslash, which basically
means that if I wanted to print
something on a new line here,
I can use backslash n and--
or I can do a tab or I
can use a single quotation
mark, what have you.
So let's take a look here
in my print statement
that I just did in
my last example.
Say that I want to
print, My name is Reagan.
And then on a new line, I want
to say an I am 420 months old.
So now when I run
this, you'll notice
that it says, my name
is Reagan, new line,
and I am 420 months old.
So you can format strings in
really interesting way using
those, we call them
escape characters,
their backslashes
with that code,
that backslash end for new
line or for tab what have you.
So that's a good example
of another introduction
to programming.
Continue on in our videos.
Thanks for your hard work.